gracias por continuar en la pantalla de
france en 24 el momento de conocer las
principales noticias en materia
económica de américa latina y del resto
del mundo y lo haremos por supuesto con
nuestro compañero luis méndez zurich
swiss muy buenas noches vamos a comenzar
en eeuu ya se dieron a conocer los datos
del déficit presupuestario así que
santiago este alcanzó los dos puntos 77
billones de dólares y es el segundo más
alto en la nación detrás de los 3 puntos
13 billones alcanzados el año pasado de
acuerdo a lo informado por la
administración de joe wright en las
líneas generales del déficit en el
período presupuestario que culminó el 30
de septiembre fueron 360 mil millones
más bajo que el del año 2020 como
porcentaje de la economía medido por el
producto interno bruto la cifra
representa el 14,4 por ciento pero un
comunicado conjunto del departamento del
tesoro y la oficina de gestión de
presupuesto señaló que el bajo porque
bajo el gobierno de job aire en la
economía está
encaminándose históricamente la nación
había presentado un alto déficit solo en
2009 cuando este fuerte 14 billones de
dólares le damos a dorada para hablar de
una medida que se está implementando que
se va a implementar mejor dicho se
anunciaron precios congelados para los
combustibles así es una medida que ya
fue anunciada por el presidente de ese
país este viernes y surge como un
intento para calmar las protestas en
contra del ejecutivo por las reformas
que pretende llevar a cabo y también por
la aparición de guillermo lasso en los
llamados papeles de pandora vale
recordar que tras las protestas de 2019
por el intento del entonces presidente
lenin moreno de eliminar los subsidios
el país estableció un sistema de bandas
donde el precio del combustible fluctúa
va a la par del precio del barril de
petróleo pero el alza del precio del
crudo este año ha elevado los precios un
40 por ciento en lo que va de año pero
escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo el
presidente de lazo al respecto se
suspenden los incrementos mensuales de
los precios de los combustibles y a
partir de ahora se establece el precio
de la gasolina extra
en 2 dólares
55 centavos el galón y de igual manera
el precio del diesel se establece en un
dólar 90 bueno les continuamos ahora en
mexico se dieron a conocer los datos de
la inflación quinquenal así ese y este
en los primeros 15 días del mes de
octubre se ubicó en 0 5% con ello elevó
el dato de inflación en un año a 6 12%
es la más alta desde la segunda quincena
del mes de diciembre del año 2017 para
el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador el fenómeno es transitorio y
aseguró que hará lo necesario para
evitar que el indicador siga aumentando
pero escuchamos que otras cosas dio
préstamos este procurando que no aumente
la inflación porque eso afecta la
economía popular
pero yo considero que va a ser un asunto
de este transitorio pasajero
y que vamos a
tener
pronto
una disminución de inflación bueno luis
de méxico hacemos un largo viaje hasta
rusia porque el banco de este país subió
la tasa de referencia de que estamos
hablando estamos hablando de la tasa de
referencia del país y que se toma como
una medida para combatir la inflación
pero el incremento de 75 puntos bases
estuvo por encima de las expectativas de
los analistas con ello la tasa de
referencia se ubicó en 7 50 por ciento y
lo que se busca es disminuir la demanda
agregada al tiempo que se reduce la
cantidad de dinero disponible dentro de
la economía así las autoridades buscan
disminuir la inflación que se situó en
7,4 por ciento a nivel interanual en el
mes de septiembre desde el 67 por ciento
el mes de agosto los datos de elvira
nabiúllina señalan que éstos están por
encima de las proyecciones del año bueno
continuamos con los indicadores de la
jornada que nos dicen cierre mixtos en
wall street por las caídas en standard
and poor's y también el nasdaq compuesto
en europa hubo si respecto por esta vez
cayó el ibex 35 de españa cierre
positivo en el mercado japonés esta es
la noticia del pago de berga o cierres
mixtos en américa latina donde destacan
las caídas de méxico brasil y colombia
cerramos con la habitual cifra del día
cuales tiene que ver con los 1.762 7
millones de dólares que alcanzó en el
tercer trimestre en ventas la empresa de
juguetes mattel la que fabrica parte
gracias a la dispuesta crónica económica
completísima a nuestra audiencia le
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com sigan con nosotros
[Música]
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]